This is Jocko podcast number
15 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
I looked around at the men.
Yeah,
I was the only one looking around.
All the other heads were bowed down.
All of them
praying.
These men were going into battle.
Real battle.
We could literally hear machine gun fire
in the distance where the battle would
take place.
These men had suffered an
incredible number of casualties.
They had every reason to pray.
I was with Charlie company
from one of the most hallowed
units in the u s military.
The first of the five oh six the
band of brothers made famous by their
unbelievable performance in World War II,
which was documented in
the book band of brothers,
which became an HBO mini
series of the same name.
The first of the five oh six in Ramadi
held the line on that tradition of glory
and service and courage.
There's nothing I can say that
will do justice to the end, to the,
to the admiration and the respect that
I had for the first of the five oh six
and that all of us seals had
for the first of the five oh six
the seals that I sent to work directly
with the five oh six they became adopted
by the five oh six red Currahee. That's
one of the nicknames for the five Oh six
and the seals that were directly,
they're working with them absolutely
loved the five oh six the Bible six
represented everything good.
I can imagine in a
military team or any team,
professional and disciplined
and motivated and creative.
The leadership in the battalion
was absolutely outstanding.
The battalion commander,
he was the very essence of leadership.
He was calm and direct and friendly and
open minded and respectful and respected
and his staff and the company
commanders in the senior NCO,
they had this unified thread between them,
this bond,
this connection,
and it was that tradition in that sense,
purpose and that standard of
excellence and professionalism.
It's hard to describe,
but it was absolutely there and it was
as real as the sand and the bullets and
the guns.
And so there I was,
and this was early in my deployment to
Ramadi with task unit bruiser and I was
about to go out into the [inaudible]
district with Charlie Company
and their company commander
was just an outstanding guy.
And I knew that this unit in this company,
in this battalion,
I knew it was something special
and I knew that that term,
the band of brothers,
I knew that that's what they truly were.
And we hear it and I know it's a book
in, it's uh, it's a, it's an HBO series,
but
where does it come from now most
people have heard that simple quote,
we few,
we happy few.
We band of brothers for he today that
sheds his blood with me shall be my
brother.
And I knew what that quote was.
I knew where it came from.
I was an English major in college
and I knew that that was Shakespeare.
And I knew that that was Henry the fifth.
And I knew how powerful that quote was.
Now when you start talking
about Shakespeare and you
start talking about Henry
the fifth, there's all kinds of
different directions you can go
because you can go back and you can
look at what Henry the fifth was like in
real life.
And if he was like the leader that
Shakespeare made him into into play.
And you could talk about Shakespeare
himself and the rumors and the,
and the myths and the lay,
the legends that circulate
his life and his legacy.
Because there's all kinds of
questions about Shakespeare. I mean,
did he actually write all of his place?
Was He more than one person?
Was he a soldier at some point?
How did he know all this stuff about the
military and what it was like to be a
soldier?
Was his vocabulary 10 times
what a normal person is?
There's all kinds of,
like I said,
rumor and myth about Shakespeare,
but instead of talking about all that and,
and the conjecture and the
hypothetical questions,
I would rather talk about
something that is known,
something that we have today.
And those are the words,
words from the play.
Henry the fifth,
which yes was written by Shakespeare,
and
I'm going to tell you, don't be scared
and don't be intimidated by that.
I mean don't be scared and
don't be intimidated by
Shakespeare because you don't
understand it because you can't.
Then the fact of the matter is
no one can,
at least at first,
it's not possible to understand
Shakespeare out of the gate.
It doesn't work. It's a
nother language. It's,
it's, it is a another language. You
can't be expected to understand it.
It's written in something
called early modern English.
You don't we speak English.
This is early modern English,
which is just a transition from
something called middle English,
and if you go on youtube and you look
up middle English and you have somebody
read, a real common one is, if you look
at the Lord's prayer in middle English,
you can barely understand it.
Parts of it,
you can't understand parts
of the world you recognize,
but when you get to early modern
English now with a step closer,
but it still is. There's,
there's, it's different.
It's a different type of language and
there's archaic words and there's obsolete
words and there's words that
Shakespeare just made up.
He would make up words factually.
And the patterns of speech are different
in the idioms are different and the
references are all historical.
And so if you don't have a grasp on those
mythological references and historical
references and biblical references than
it doesn't have the meaning that it's
supposed to have.
So you can't expect just to open up
Shakespeare and be able to understand it.
Now this is actually the opposite of
what I often say because to me, you know,
you hear me say all the time that what
makes English show important is that you
can make things very simple and
very understandable by everybody.
So then why is it important?
Why should we read it?
Why should we try and understand it?
And the answer that question
is actually very simple.
Shakespeare had something,
he had something, he had some
understanding, some knowledge,
some,
some insight into the human
mind that is not normal.
It's not normal.
He understood people
deeply.
You understood relationships,
he understood leadership, he
understood love. And he understood war,
and I don't know how he did this and
I'm going to why he did, but he did.
And on top of that,
he had this talent.
He had this gift to translate
that knowledge into words.
And this is important because in the
late 15 hundreds in the early 16 hundreds
this is a whole nother deal.
There's no special effects.
There's no close up shots of an actor.
There's no stunt man,
there's no CGI.
Everything has to be
contained in the words,
all the emotion and all the feeling
and all they action and all the nature
of human beings.
It all has to be captured in the words.
And the words that
Shakespeare uses are heavy
and they're also,
they're power regnant their power regnant
with so much more meaning than what's
on the surface.
They're filled with depth and knowledge
that you have to scrape away and uncover
to figure out what they're
even talking about.
But let's,
let's take a look at this,
this famous speech in Henry,
the fifth,
the play,
the same name
and I'm going to lead into it a little
bit just to kind of at least set the
context of what's happening. And
as I did, as I went into my notes,
just the opening,
when you've got this guy that kind of
comes out and describes to you what's
going to happen in the play
in the end,
he kind of introduces Henry,
they call him Harry
and he introduces him with this line.
Then should the war like Harry,
like himself assume the port of Mars
and at his heels leached in like hounds
should famine,
sword and fire crouch forward employment.
So if you break that down,
first of all he's coming out of the great
out of the gate he's saying Harry is
warlike,
which means he's fond of war and skilled
in it and equipped for it and in a more
literal meaning,
it's saying Henry is like war himself,
which means he has complexities and the
and the youth and the mayhem and the
chaos inside himself.
And then it goes on to say that
he should assume the port of Mars,
which means he should take
on the bearing of Mars,
which is the Roman God
of war and at his heels.
So, so down now by his
feet. Leashed in hounds.
So you've got dogs,
angry dogs on leashes,
and those dogs are famine,
sword and fire.
And in those days that was war because
when you did siege warfare on somebody,
you locked down their castle,
you starve them.
And once they were weekend,
you burned their castle and then
use the sword to finish him off.
So he had those dogs of war at his side
and they were crouched for employment.
If you could imagine a pit bull just
tents and coiled like a spring ready to
pounce.
That's the opening to describe Henry.
So
they're at war with France and they go
to take down this town of horror fleur.
And at this point,
this is one of the other really famous
speeches from Henry the fifth and at this
point they've broken through
the walls and there's a,
there's a breach in the wall. So
there's a, there's a hole in the wall,
but the French are still defending it.
The French are still
defending it pretty well.
And so Henry has a little
chat with his troopers.
And this is a pretty famous speech.
And he says once more unto the breach,
dear friends,
once more or close the wall
up with our English dead.
So he's saying that hole in the wall,
charge it charge at and either get through
it or fill up the wall with our dead.
And then he says in peace there's nothing
so becomes a man as modest stillness
and humility. So when things
are, when things are peaceful,
being calm and being
humble is a good thing.
But when the blast of
war blows in our ears,
then imitate the action of the tiger.
So when war comes, nevermind peace and
calm, it's time to be like a tiger.
And he says, stiff in the
sinews. Summon up the blood,
disguise fair nature
with hard favored rage.
So tense your body and
summing up your rage.
Then lend the I a terrible aspect.
Let pry through the portage of the head,
like the brass cannon.
Let the brow overwhelm it.
So what he's saying there is furrow your
brow and let your eye poke through your
brow.
Like a cannon,
like a brass cannon
sticking out of a porthole
as fearfully as Dothan
Gollad rock overhang.
And Judie is confounded based swilled
with the wild and wasteful ocean.
So he's saying,
make your brow over,
hang your eyes like a rock that
Drudge's out over the wild ocean.
And then now set the teeth
and stretch the nostril wide.
Hold hard the breadth and bend up
every spirit to its full height.
So you know what that one is?
Bite down. Grit your teeth,
flair your nostrils.
Take a deep breath and hold it in and
bring every emotion you have to its utmost
and like, like a, like a tension on a bow
on, on, you know, balist English,
whose blood is Fed from
fathers of war proof fathers.
Like so many Alexander's having these
parts from morning till even fought and
she their swords for lack of
argument. So he's saying, listen,
you gotta fight,
you gotta fight you.
You Englishman whose blood is from
combat tested warriors like Alexander the
Great
and those men have fought on this
soil from morning until night forever.
And they only she their swords when
there was no one else to fight.
Do not dishonor your mothers.
Now a test that whom you
called fathers did beget you
don't dishonor your mom.
Prove that your father with his
warrior blood is really your father.
Be Copy now to men of grocer
blood and teach them how to war.
And that means being an
example to the lesser man,
to the weaker man and show them how to war
and you good yeoman who's
limbs were made in England?
Show us here the metal of your pasture.
So yeoman,
we're basically like the troopers that
foot soldiers in the archers and he's
saying show us how you were
born in England and the pasture.
That's where you were raised like
a cow was raised on a pasture.
Show us what the metal of that pasture is.
Let us swear that you are
worth for your breeding,
which I doubt not for
there is none of you.
So mean and base that half not
know baluster in your eyes.
So no matter where these guys are from,
no matter what level of society
they're they they came from,
he sees the noble luster in the
righteous gleam in their eyes.
I see you stand like
grey hounds in the slips,
straining upon the start
now grey hounds, you know,
now we use them for racing.
They used to be used to have
to run down animals and a slip
is, and this is one of those
things, you've got to look this up.
I didn't know this,
I looked it up today.
A slip is an old kind of leash that they
used for hunting dogs that when you,
it was very,
you could,
you could basically hit a switch
and it would let the dog go.
So here are these pictures of these
greyhounds that are in these quick release
leashes,
but they're straining on them weeding to
go on the hunt to go in and chase down
their prey.
And the next line is the game's afoot.
Follow your spirit and upon this charge,
cry God for Harry England and St George.
So he says the game's afoot, meaning
that the animal that you're hunting,
it's out there.
Follow your spirit and
then go and get after it.
And as you get after it,
Yell God for Harry England
and St George and St Georges,
St George's, the patron saint
of England, the dragon slayer,
who was an executed Christian martyr.
So
you can see that there's so much insight,
these words,
and he captures some of the brutality
of war.
And so what happens now is they,
they get the village that they're trying
to take down and they've, you know,
put a lot of pressure on.
They've gone through the breach,
they've gotten fight back,
but now they've got them on the lockdown
and
he's telling them,
he tells the governor,
Henry tells the governor that he needs
to surrender before Henry loses control
of his own men. This is a scary
thing. This is like, you know, hey,
if you don't surrender now, I'm not
gonna have control anymore. Right?
Over these guys,
these barbarians at the gate,
they're going to come and I'm not going
to have control over them anymore.
He says,
yes,
the gates of mercy shall be all shut up
and the flesh should soldier rough and
hard of heart. And by the
way flesh. It is an old word.
It means excited by the taste of flesh.
So he's saying these soldiers who are
excited by the taste of flesh in liberty
of bloody hand sell shall range
with conscience wide as hell.
So in liberty of bloody hand,
you know what that means?
It means our hands already
covered in blood. I'm good.
I'm just going to go forward. I don't
care anymore. I don't care anymore
with conscious wide as hell.
Mowing like grass,
your fresh fare virgins
and your flowering infants.
So we are going to come and we
are going to mow like grass.
Your virgin is and your children.
That's that.
Okay.
He goes on trying to convince them again,
this is his key point is like,
listen, I have control of these
guys right now and he goes on,
therefore you men of horror,
fleur,
take pity on your town
and have your people.
Whilst yet my soldiers are in my command
wiles yet the cool and to wind of grace
or blows the fill fee and contain
just clouds of heady murder,
spoil and villainy.
So he's saying like right now there's,
there's a cool breeze of
peace and grace with my guys,
but some contagious clouds are coming
of murder and spoil and villainy and,
and the word to use this heady
is it means intoxicating,
meaning these kinds are
going to lose their minds
if not,
why in a moment,
look to see the blind and bloody soldier
with foul hand desire the locks of your
shrill shrieking daughters.
Your father's taken by the silver beards
and their most river reverend heads
dash to the walls,
blind and bloody show to get.
It's like blind with rage and
blind with murder and foul hands.
He's telling them this,
you're naked infants.
Spitted upon pikes
in spitted by the way,
is a
methodology used in this time period
for cooking small game, small animals.
And it means you put the animal on a
pole from mouth to rectum and he's saying
they're going to do this to their children
walls. The madd, mothers
with their howls, confused,
do break the clouds,
as did the wives of jewelry at how at
Harrods bloody hunting slaughterman so
break the clouds.
That means cries to the Madd.
Mothers are going to go mad with tiers
like they did in the Bible in Matthew
Two 16. That's what this is referring to.
When King Herod ordered the slaughter
of all boys under the age of two in
Bethlehem,
this is like a threat that they're
going to kill all the children.
So Henry the fifth is bringing it
home.
What say you,
will you yield and of this avoid or
guilty in defense be thus destroyed.
So the
French hearing these pretty
valid threats coming, uh,
they surrender.
They
Henry and the troops take that village
and then the next thing they do is march
in.
And again,
I'm moving rapidly through a real war
that took place and they end up settling
on the opposing ends of a field,
which is now what's becomes the,
the famous battle of it.
Some people call it as in court
or Agincourt and the French,
they, they got more people.
I mean, it's in France.
So they've got more people,
substantially more people.
And there's a bunch of different,
you are on the books, I've read,
there's varying numbers, but they
definitely had substantially more people.
And Henry,
he's talking to some of his leadership,
his subordinate commanders,
and then they all kind of walk off the
stage and he's left there and he starts
talking a little bit about
the burden of command and,
and some thoughts on leadership,
which I was,
I found very familiar.
So he says upon the king,
let us our lives,
our souls,
our debts are careful wives,
our children and our sins lay on the king.
We must bear all.
So he knows that the king is
responsible for everything.
Got To take ownership of everything.
Hmm.
And he,
he kind of talks about
this idea that the king is,
it's, you know, it's, it's the
expression of it's lonely at the top.
He's about to get into
that in whatever it was,
1599 oh ceremony show me.
But I worth, what is the
soul of adoration? Art,
thou ought else but place, degree
and form. So he's saying like,
what is all this junk besides
just social rank and etiquette?
What real meaning does it have creating
all in fear in other men wearing in vow
art, less happy being
feared than they inferior.
So he's saying,
look like these people are scared of me.
[inaudible] I'm actually less happy than
they are. They're, they're afraid of me,
but I'm less happy because I'm
the guy that's scaring them.
I am a king that find the,
and I know tis not the bomb,
the sector and the ball, the sword
that may face the crown imperial,
the Inter tissued robe of Golden Pearl,
the Farsad title,
running for the king,
the throne he sits on nor the tide of
pump that beats upon the high shore of
this world.
So he go through all of the kind of
stereotypical things that make you a king,
you know the clothes, the Septor,
the crown, all those things.
No,
not all these thrice gorgeous ceremony.
Not all these laid in bed majestical
so not any of those beautiful things.
Expensive things can sleep so
soundly as the wretched slave.
So it's the slave who with a body
filled and vacant mind gets him to rest,
crammed with distressful bread.
So he's talking about
this fact that the king
doesn't get to rest. He doesn't get to
sleep when the slave goes home at night.
Yeah, he's gonna eat the Fed
with and distressful basically.
That means that they made it themselves.
They made with their own hands,
they actually get some satisfaction
of making their food and eating it.
He didn't even get that satisfaction.
His mind is constantly churning
about the fate of the kingdom.
And you know this actually,
interestingly, when I was in a,
I know we did a podcast here about Sri
Lanka and I talked about me being in Sri
Lanka and I, I tried to drag is because
again, I'd never been in combat.
This is the mid ninety's.
And I tried to drag as much knowledge
as I could out of the Sri Lankan guys,
the Shawangunk and military in this
trunk and Special Boat Service in this
special forces guys that we were working
with. And they were unbelievably, uh,
combat experienced veterans.
But one of the guys that I befriended
who is an army captain and you know his,
he, he was one of those guys who's a
guy that was a good leader. But man,
he felt exactly what this got what, what
Henry the fifth is talking about here.
And I remember him saying,
you know,
he's kind of just having a late night
conversation with me. Cause like I said,
I was constantly trying to garner
information from these guys and learn from
them. And you know, he gets
this guy had been at, this guy,
had been a regular soldier
and then he had been promoted.
He'd gone up the ranks and
he said, you know, Jocko,
when I was a soldier, meaning when he
was just a grunt soldier and you know,
lower enlisted guy,
he said,
I knew I could survive anything and
I knew I could take care of myself.
And it was actually kind of fun.
And he said,
now that Omar Company commander, cause
now we use actually a pretty senior guy.
He said,
it is the most stress in it is the most
harrowing thing because I am not worried
about myself anymore, but I'm so
worried about all these other guys.
That's what the worry is. And Yeah, I uh,
I actually got to know
that feeling myself. Hmm.
The leader gets no rest in the end.
And what Henry's talking about
is that burden of command.
That's the same thing that Sri
Lankan guy was talking about.
And you hear me talking about it as well.
You know,
that burden of command is heavy.
And now, so now, you know, again,
I've kind of gone very
quickly through what this,
to get to this point where we're Henry
the fifth makes this famous speech.
And as I said,
the English on one side of the battlefield
in the French or the other. Again,
this really happened,
this is,
this is factual information and they
can hear each other and they can not at
night they see each other's campfires
burning in any English. Like I said,
they know they're outnumbered. And
finally one of the leaders, you know,
as they're, as they're getting
ready to go into combat,
one of the leaders from the British side,
he calls out kind of like
wishing that they had more men.
And it's interesting and it's
pretty important to know that,
I mean, obviously Shakespeare
fictionalized this in many ways,
but that speech is actually
rooted in a real account.
It's rooted in a real account
of something that was said.
And,
and,
and the account was written
by an anonymous chaplain
that was like on tour with
these guys.
And he just wrote down what he saw.
And in his report it was the,
uh,
a guy named Sir Walter Hungerford that
suggested to the king that it would be
nice if they had another 10,000 orchards
from England that we're not doing
anything, you know, that are sitting
back doing, you know, back in England,
sitting in peace. And it'd be nice if
they had in there. And now in the play,
it's a character named Westmoreland,
who's one of, you know, this, the,
the lieutenants or the, one of the, uh,
subordinate leadership of Henry
the fifth. And he says, oh,
that we now had here,
but one 10,000 of those men in
England that do no work today.
So he's saying that same
thing. He's like, listen,
here we are about to go to battle.
We're completely outnumbered
and
be nice if we had some of those other
guys that are in England right now that
are sitting in bed, they're
doing nothing. And so,
so now King Henry Responds and,
and again this is,
this is in the same vein that was
documented by this anonymous chaplain.
And of course Shakespeare wrote it. So
it's gotta be, it's a lot more impactful,
but the message is the same.
And I'm going to go through this
once and kind of break it down. So,
so that we can understand what the meaning
of these different words are before I
just roll through it.
So when he see her,
this guy says, you know, if only we
had more guys and King Henry says,
what's he that wishes?
So meaning who just set that said,
my cousin Westmoreland.
No, my fair cousin,
if we are marked to die,
we are enough to do our
country loss and if to live,
the fewer men,
the greater share of honor.
So he's saying, no, listen,
if we're going to die,
we've got plenty of guys
here to die for our country.
But if we're going to live and if we're
going to win, the fewer men we have,
the better because
that's more honor for us.
Hmm.
God's will.
I pray thee wish not one more man.
He doesn't want anybody else by jove.
I am not covetous for gold nor
care I who doth feed upon my cost.
So he doesn't care about gold.
He doesn't care who he feeds and who,
who eats off of his
check that he is cashing.
It earns me not if my men,
my garments wear meaning isn't people.
He didn't care if people are either taking
his clothes or if they're wearing his
world colors. It doesn't care.
Doesn't care about any of that.
Such outward things
dwell not in my desires.
Those things don't matter to him.
But if it,
if it be a sin to covet honor,
I am the most offending soul alive.
So if it's about honor and if it's
a sin to want honor and want glory,
that he's the guiltiest person of a mall.
No faith my Coz wish,
not a man from England,
God's peace.
I would not so great an honor as a one
more man me thinks would share from me
for the best hope I have.
Oh, do not waste one more.
So he's just going off like,
no, we don't want anyone else.
I don't want to share my
honor with anyone else.
Rather proclaim it Westmoreland
through my host that he,
which hath no stomach to this fight.
Let him depart his passport shall be
made and crowns for convoy put into his
purse. So is it okay? You
know what, Westmoreland,
as a matter of fact,
tell everyone that anybody that doesn't
have the guts or the stomach to stand
here with us and fight,
tell him I'll give him a passport and
I'll give them money to pay for their trip
home.
We would not die in that man's company
that fears his fellowship to die with us.
He doesn't want to die with
anybody that fears that duty.
That's what they mean by fellowship.
The duty to die with us
this day is called the
feast of Crispian Crispian.
This is actually alleged twin brothers.
Interestingly,
Crispin Crispian twin brothers,
they help the poor and they preach
Christianity and they were tortured by the
Roman governor and they were thrown
into the river with millstones,
tied around their necks and they
survived and when they survive that,
they pulled him out of the
water and they beheaded them.
Okay?
They were venerated and they became
saints on October 25th and that's called
Saint Crispin's Day.
Sometimes it's called sync crispy ins day,
but that's what it is.
So this day,
this is October 25th when
they're about to fight, he says,
this day is called the feast of Crispian.
He that outlives this
day and comes home safe.
We'll stand a tiptoe when the day is
named and rouse him at the name of
Crispian.
Is there anybody that anybody that lives
through this day and comes home safe
when it's going to be Saint Crispin's Day,
they're going to get on their toes.
They're going to be so excited about it.
He that she'll see this
day and live old age,
will yearly on the vigil feast,
his neighbors and say,
tomorrow is Saint Crispian.
So again,
anybody that lives through this is going
to be going to their neighbors and say,
hey,
tomorrow Saint Crispin's Day,
then
will he strip his sleeve and show his
scars and say these wounds I had on
Crispin's Day,
so he's gonna be at their feet.
He's going to roll up his sleeves and
he's going to say, you see these scars?
These are what I got on Crispin's Day
old men forget yet all shall be forgot.
But he'll remember with advantages
what feats he did that day.
So he's saying everything gets forgotten,
right?
But the old man will remember the glory
days of that battle and what he did,
it will be the highlight of his life.
Then our names familiar in
his mouth as household words.
Harry, the King Bedford and
Exeter, Warwick and Talbot,
Salisbury and Gloucester
be in their flowing cups,
freshly remembered.
So all their names are
going to be remembered.
This story shall the good man teach his
son and Crispin Crispian shall ne'er go
by from this day to the
ending of the world.
But we in it shall be
remembered. We say, look,
this is a story that good men are going
to tell their sons and their gonna
forever. Remember on this day
till the ending of the world,
what we did,
we few,
we happy few.
We band of brothers for he today that
sheds his blood with me shall be my
brother.
And that one doesn't
really need an explanation,
but we just shared.
You hear about Brotherhood a lot.
Yeah.
Be He ne'er so vile this day
shall gentle his condition.
So no matter where you're from,
no matter what you were like,
no matter what kind of
a person you were today,
when he says gentle his condition that
today we'll make you a gentleman today
we'll make you a man
and gentlemen in England.
Now we're bed.
So guys that are back in England right
now sleeping shall think themselves or
curse it.
They were not here and hold their manhoods
cheap whilst any speaks that fought
with us upon Saint Crispin's Day.
So like I said,
anyone that's home in
England and that word a bed,
it's like implies being lazy and sleeping.
They're going to curse that they
weren't there and they'll know that they
weren't real men. And Emma,
he used the word manhood,
which implies,
you know,
testicular fortitude [inaudible] they
didn't have the testicular fortitude to
fight.
And that's,
that's
the speech with the understanding.
And I haven't even gone all the way.
I mean,
I didn't go to break down each and every
word and the depth and meaning behind
them because they are so impactful.
And if you go and you read, you can
get like a translated modern version,
um, that kind of dumbs down
the language and that's okay.
But I'm telling you, having
done both, when you do that,
that's like compared to actually doing
the work and studying and figuring out
what it all actually means.
If you just take a dumbed down version,
it's like Diet Shakespeare
or Shakespeare, right? It's,
it's actually worse than that.
It's like that.
It's like firing a cap gun
versus firing a real gun.
It kind of looks the same. And it
might even sound a little bit the same,
but one of them will kill you. Yeah. And
the other one just goes bang. You know,
it's not as heavy. And what's
really bizarre, and this is,
I think actually this is really strange.
If you go on Youtube
and you look up
Henry the fifth St Crispin's Day
speech, right? If you look it up,
you'll get these classically
trained actors famous.
I mean,
famous actors doing this speech
and in my mind,
yeah.
Okay.
They don't get it. They don't get
it. Right. And I bet you know what,
I know I'm a nobody.
I know I'm just some guy in these people
are people that studied Shakespeare and
did it on stage and all of a sudden
I'm just an ignorant, uh, you know,
Rach from the trenches and I don't
understand I am the pentameter and all the
other little details,
but I'm telling you,
I don't think they get it.
And when I watch the
professionals do this,
I don't think they get the
emotion. I don't think they
understand the leadership.
I don't think they get the fear
and the blood and the death.
And I don't think they understand war.
And when these actors
take these great words
better crafted brilliantly,
and they try and say
them like leaders to me,
they still sound like actors.
They don't sound like
men that have fought.
men that had seen battle.
They definitely don't sound
like men that have seen war.
I think Henry,
the fifth would have sounded different.
This is what
I think would be closer to what Henry
the fifth a combat leader would have
sounded like as he,
as he answered some one of his subordinate
leaders out there in the crowd saying
that we need more people.
We need more men.
I think this is what he
would have sounded like.
What's he that wishes? So
my cousin Westmoreland,
no, my fair cousin, if
we are marked to die,
we are enough to do our country
loss and if to live the fewer men,
the greater share of honor,
God's will.
I pray thee wish.
Not One more man
by jove.
I am not covetous for gold nor
care I who doth feed upon my cost.
It earns me not if men,
my garments wear such outward
things dwell not in my desires,
but if it be a sin to covet honor,
I am the most offending soul alive.
No faith, my Coz wish,
not a man from England.
God's peace.
I would not lose so great an honor as one
man more me thinks would share from me
for the best hope I have.
O do not wish one more.
Rather proclaim it Westmoreland through
my host that he which hath no stomach to
this fight.
Let him depart his passport shall be
made and crowns for convoy shall be put
into his purse.
We would not die in that man's company
that fears his fellowship to die with us.
This Day is called the feast of Crispian.
He that outlives this
day and comes home safe.
We'll stand a tiptoe when the day is
named and rouse him at the name of
Crispian.
He that shall see this day and live old
age will yearly on the vigil feast his
neighbors and say,
tomorrow is Saint Crispian.
Then will he strip his sleeve and show
his scars and say these wounds I had on
Crispin's Day
old men forget
yet all shall be forgot,
but he'll remember with advantages
what feats he did that day.
Then shall our names familiar
in his mouth as household words.
Harry, the King Bedford and
Exeter, Warwick and Talbot,
Salisbury and Gloucester
be in their flowing cups,
freshly remembered
this story shall the
good man teach his son
and Crispin Crispian shall ne'er go by
from this day to the ending of the world.
But we in it shall be.
Remember it, we few,
we happy few.
We band of brothers
for cook for he today that sheds his
blood with me shall be my brother.
Be Ne'er so vile this day
shall gentle his condition
and gentlemen in England now a bed
shall think themselves or curse it.
They were not here and hold their manhoods
cheap was any speaks that fought with
us
upon Saint Crispin's Day.
Now that is a speech
and that is,
like I said,
there's a lot more to
it then what I covered,
there's so much depth there and that's
why it's lasted the ages and that's why
you hear people talking about brotherhood
and this is what they refer to.
And as far as Shakespeare goes,
and I talk all the time about getting
stronger and faster and getting smarter
and stronger and faster.
That's okay.
I mean that's pretty straightforward.
How do you get stronger and faster?
You lose weight, you workout,
you do your calisthenics,
you do physical activity
to get stronger and faster.
But how do you get smarter?
Well,
this is one way to get smarter.
You go out and you find something that
you do not understand and you gain
understanding of it.
Words you don't know and phrases you
don't know and concepts that you don't
know. You find them and you
learn them. You teach yourself.
The resources are there,
and by the way, you know what? It's free.
There's no gym fees,
there's no equipment to,
you can get all of Shakespeare,
his entire cannon on
the Internet for free.
It's at the library for free.
The only thing it does take in,
the only thing it does cost is just a
little something that we call discipline,
right? To get in there, to open
that book, to challenge your brain
in order to free your mind.
So that's Shakespeare.
That's Henry the fifth and
very impactful
and definitely a classic representation
of the band of brothers that I had the
honor to work with
in Ramadi,
Iraq in 2006 the first of the five oh six.
And I guess it is time for
questions from the Inter webs
and uh,
speaking of the interwebs,
little something from Ana. Yes. Yeah.
We are in fact sponsored by
[inaudible] dot com boom.
Which is where Jack, we'll get to this
krill oil to keep, we'll say what?
Aging joints.
No,
we'll just say joints
did not deteriorating.
We'll just say aging joints to
keep his joints together. Um,
sorry.
I get some Alpha brain.
That's why I'm so smart
and my memory's so good.
I'm actually encouraging you
to take more Alpha brain. Yeah,
it's up the game a little bit.
What? It's good. Um, yeah.
So on it.com and get some
and you can get some, uh,
get some kettle bells and some club
bells and go and toss those things around
and get yourself a little bit stronger.
Get them in on it. That myself. I've,
I have a few Zombie bells at the house
and you probably used Allen. I have them.
I have them.
They're my,
they're my kind of go to when I have them
sitting around because they, they do.
They kind of draw you in because I see,
what do I think when I see Zombie,
when I see zombies,
I think Zombie apocalypse.
I think I've been rewriting
something like, oh,
it hit a couple of kettlebell snatches
real quick while I got a little the
little two minutes spare.
Boom. Hold up there.
And they're dope though. And apparently
they're balanced just like regular ones.
Yeah. No, they feel they feel not all it.
You know when you can get them@onit.com
o n n I t.com/jocko and you get 10% off.
Boom.
Get some shroom tech sport
while you're the shroom texts.
I think lever as a public service.
Yeah.
If you're doing something that's high
output, like a crossfit situations,
that's a public telling you night
and day anyway. Shroom tech sport.
That's the one I'm going to
go on the shirt to explore
it, I think. I don't think.
See what's up.
Thank you.
Shit it then what about
the amazon.com yes.
If you would like to support
this podcast in a painless way,
we'd call it painless, seamless,
seamless, and painless squads. I seamless,
instead of going straight to amazon.com
go to Jocko store.com or Jocko podcast,
buy a TV flat screen,
plasma TV for $800. Right,
and you could do it through,
you do it through,
you click through Jocko,
podcast.com or Jocko store.com.
Sure. Then in the podcast,
get supported financially. Yeah. I get to
like, you know a little little Samsung.
That's cool. It's better than
nothing. Yeah, and it's, yeah,
an actually Amazon pages
because, because, yeah.
That's cool because it takes time to do
the podcast, right? It takes preparation.
Do the podcast. Yeah, and you
know what? I'm going to be
honest, bro. I do it anyway.
Obviously I think you would do, but we did
it, but people ask though, they're like,
hey, this is great. Let's to people,
they'll, they'll sign up somebody,
I guess other podcasts,
they'll have situations where you can
sign up and just enter your credit card
and it'll take out like a dollar a month
or something as like a thing. This guy,
um, I for totally forget his
name, such a cool way. Anyway,
emailed me and told me that I
was like, Dang, that's solid.
But nonetheless we do that.
It's necessary,
but I dunno,
I think we're just,
maybe we'll research that because I
deal with people would always say, hey,
how can we support?
Because people are getting value and when
they get value they want to give value.
They want to give you something back,
which is awesome. Yeah. I appreciate that.
Yeah. Very cool. Very cool. Yeah.
I mean the prep notes today,
we're 17 pages long working on
for the past few days. Yeah.
Getting Ready. You know, that's
like a term paper in college,
you know those grinders total gut check.
Yeah.
It's like a 400 level term paper.
My term papers or one page. Yeah,
one paid college athlete
over there and uh, oh yeah.
One more thing about about
Amazon. Somebody hit me up
on Twitter and said, hey,
you need to say on your
podcast that you have your,
your book extreme ownership is
an audio book. Yeah. And what,
what I think is cool about it is
leaf who wrote the book with me?
He's another seal.
He worked with me in Ramadi and he
and I are the ones that read it.
So we each wrote chapters. We wrote
half the chapters and we reread it.
So you know if you're used to
the Jocko podcast voice. Yeah.
And annual life was on the podcast,
obviously podcast number 11 so we get,
you can get the audio book and you
got another, it's eight hours long.
It's no joke. If you got a long
drive, eight hour drive. Yeah.
Get she got an eight hour drive.
Francisco from San Diego. Yeah. Yeah.
That's one of those drives. It's good.
Okay. Yeah. So Dzongkha store.com
Jocko,
podcast.com all right. In
on it. Oh in in it.com.
Thanks. [inaudible] Bronco. Thank
you. Alright, Internet questions.
First question,
kind of a paragraph with a question.
You ever got some long questions Jocko.
I'm just curious about your opinions
on the regular army infantry.
It seems like nowadays the
regular infantry is almost
looked down upon from the
regular public in every prior
military public speaker.
I almost feel like we're looked at like
we were just bodies that held ground and
absorbed attacks.
It may no real impact on the war.
I'm almost hesitant to ask because I'm
not sure if I can or I'm not sure if I'm
in denial or if it's just pride.
I served with some fantastic warriors and
I don't want those heroes to be looked
over in history because
they were regular grunts.
So I enjoy your opinions on this matter.
And if you could enlighten
me on how infantry divisions
are looked at from other
groups and organizations.
Yeah. Um, the, I'm
this question, you
know, it, it bothers me.
It bothers me because if you couldn't
tell from the opening that I did tonight
talking about the first of five oh six
I would tell you the same thing about so
many other units that we have the utmost
respect and admiration for what we used
to call conventional for forces with
an alcohol general purpose forces.
But it's the marine corps, the the
US Marine Corps, the U S Army there,
they're regular infantry to ground
pattern there grunts and we,
like I said, the guys in my task and
at the guys that own the seal teams,
we have nothing but respect and
admiration for the ground pounders for the
grunts and for my position,
you know,
haven't been in Ramadi with the two
to eight which was a reserve unit for
Pennsylvania, that iron soldiers, those
guys were outstanding, outstanding.
And then they turned over with the 180
and you've heard me talk about them and
the battalions that were attached to them,
those guys were just the,
all of them. I mean, they were
just so professional, so brave.
And of course special forces and seals
and Rangers in Marsoc and af soc for
whatever reason.
Okay.
Special operations gets attention, right?
I mean, the name is special operations,
so it gets this attention.
I'm not 100% sure where it comes
from or where it started or whatever,
but there's something about that
that the public and the media,
okay.
And I don't know,
the media feeds the public in the foot.
The public feeds the media and
the media feeds the public.
So like the public wants to see stories.
So the media produces stories about the
special operations and then it goes into
a vicious circle,
and they just make a bunch of new
stories about it. And so, you know,
it's like this little mystique or
whatever of special operations probably
that's, that's, that's having that impact.
But let me tell you, or just for
everybody, for anyone that's on,
that's not been in the military
that has that, you know, things. Oh,
the special operations guys must be more,
you know,
elite or do more dangerous
stuff. Wrong, wrong.
Do they do dangerous stuff? Yes.
But you know, I've been all in,
when I was in Iraq, my first deployment
to Iraq, when all over Iraq is SPEC,
second deployment stayed in Ramadi.
But I during that time saw
the conventional units,
the general purpose forces that ground
pounders are grunts, the Marine Corps.
And not just them, but I talked about
this last time, the, the logistics folks,
I mean, so it's everybody,
they're out there,
they're living in forward operating basis.
They're living in combat outposts
in the middle of cities, you know,
small groups out there eating Mras
just living in really tough conditions,
doing daytime patrols and horrible areas,
working with Iraqi soldiers. Uh, you know,
like I just said to doing
these logistics runs, you know,
these where you get blown up with an Iud,
these are where you get ambushed.
I mean, this is what they did all the
time. Everyday. This was their job.
Even like the mind clearance operations,
you know,
mind you going out and you're going out
to go and get blown up or try and look
for things that are going to blow
you up. And, and you know, you first,
sure you got some guys that are in
the big mind protected vehicles.
But when we were in Ramadi,
there was a Marine Corp unit that
would follow behind those guys,
sometimes in army or they
would fall behind this.
There's sniper infantry guys just
out there getting after it. And so
what do we think of that?
I mean I have just admiration,
respect and just utmost the utmost.
I hold those guys in the highest
esteem, um, because they held the line.
So to, to that guy, the out there
that asked that question, um,
believe me,
anybody that's been in combat and knows
what you guys do and I spread that word
all the time. You listen to
any, even if you read, if you
read life, and I was book,
I mean we talk about that in great detail
about the respect and admiration we
had for, for the general purpose
forces, the grunts, the ground pounders,
the bravest,
the most professional,
the most dedicated people
that I could ever imagine.
And I was absolutely honored and everyone
in my seal task unit was honored and
humbled to have served
with such brave warriors.
So that's how I feel
about our US military.
Next question.
So Jocko posted a Twitter posts,
Instagram,
Tumblr,
Twitter and Instagram posts of a picture,
black and white strangely and sort
of my gig. Yeah, you're thinking
of just the mats and I think there was
some ambiguous figures of, he was dean,
right? Teaching somebody. Anyway,
he said talked about he learned the
lesson or something like that. Anyways,
so the question is, Jocko, what lesson
did you learn for the thousandth time?
Cause he said, he said that it was
in training with dean the other day.
So what was that last lesson? Was rules
are rules must sometimes be broken.
So let me,
let me give you the quick story.
For those of you that are Jujitsu players
will indulge you a little bit with
some Jujitsu.
So Friday night training and deny
usually train hard on Friday nights.
And we had, uh, we had a war,
we had a little death match on Friday and
it started off. We would have probably,
I don't know, five, six,
maybe seven minutes. And he
got me, got me a little, uh,
got me in a little situation
that forced me to submit.
And then we, I was like, all right, let's
go again. And so we went again and I,
and I warmed down and I
got the better of him.
And actually the deeper
water I take them into,
the better things get
for me. Right. And, uh,
so I warmed down and I got ahold
of his arm and I had him in a,
I had him in a compromised position
for probably five minutes and you know,
he, and he added the last
moments, good to great timing.
And he just got out Armbar uh,
it was a straight arm locking.
And uh, so he got out and we got out. He
was done. He was like, yeah, I'm done.
I mean, he got out of it, but he was
done. So Jocko got a little moral victory,
right. And then I kind of
antagonized him a little bit,
which is what Dean and I do. We, we
instigate and we antagonize each other.
And so I antagonized him a
little bit about, you know,
oh you don't want to train anymore. Oh
cause you're too, you're too broken down.
You know, I'm going to stay here and
train more. You can go home and you know,
have a glass of warm milk or water or you
know, just giving him a hard time. So,
so, you know, inside and
I failed to recognize this
inside. Psychologically he was,
he was not happy about that.
And so Saturday is like, Hey,
you know, let's train. And so I, I
missed that. I missed that. It's a cute,
that's a red flag. So when I showed
up, you know, he says, all, you know,
let's just work some moves.
And we went over some stuff and
work some other people and you know,
we're just kind of were very relaxed,
laid back.
There's no classical and we're just
just relaxing. And I said, hey man,
I've got to leave at such and such a time.
I can go pick one of my kids up.
He goes, yeah, yeah, no problem.
He goes, I got to leave too.
So now I think he's got to leave.
Sorry.
I'm actually thinking we might get a
light roll and that'll be it. You know,
maybe like two, five minute
rounds. So, and he's got the,
you know, have a nice guy face and
all that stuff that he's given me.
So anyways, I said, all right, you know,
we worked on some stuff that he says,
all right, let's roll real quick.
He even threw that out there.
Like it was just going to be a quick,
real quick. Yeah, just a quick role.
So I'm thinking, I'm thinking two
or three minute, I'm literally,
I'm thinking two or three minutes he'd
like to go over maybe to try some of the
stuff. We were just, we were
just drilling a little bit. No,
he comes full on, I mean, any,
any, and it was disguised full on.
So he didn't, you know, get up.
But he just went very sternly and,
and pass my guard really quick.
And then an actually,
you know,
you and I worked at,
had discussed this mountain escape that
I had done to the other day and I was
actually like on, I don't really
care if you're balanced right now.
I've got this new escape
and I'll just use that.
And he aggressively mounted
and eve aggressively went
for this move that we call
the snow angel, which is when
you get the person's arms up,
like a snow angel,
like up above their head from the mouth
and it's just horror and pin there. Yeah.
And they're in their way above. You
have no leverage. You can't move.
And so not only to me in snowy,
it's you got me a double snowing.
So both my arms are stuck up there.
Now what was bad about this was there
was a moment, okay. And this was,
this is the rule that I learned
because after we broke it down,
so dean kept me there for,
you know,
probably seven minutes in,
in double snow angel,
which is just a nightmare because
he's not just holding me there.
He's like saying things and you know,
he's antagonizing me and I'm sitting
there just wanting to kill him and uh,
I forget he,
I actually forget how it ended.
I don't remember if he went for an arm
lock and he got it or if he went and I
got out, I forget how it ended
because it's kind of a big blur,
which most of my rules are.
But anyways, the rule is,
and I don't want to go into too much
detail, be could just cause it's,
it'll get too technical and too
hard to do through an audio podcast.
But you know,
basically I don't let my elbow
cross the other person sternum.
I don't let it go across their
storm because if it does,
you can get pinned there,
you can stuck there.
So there was a moment where when Dean
was trying to move me into snow angel,
where I should have sacrificed and done
like a drastic movement that's a major
breaking of that rule and turned to my
side really hard and put my elbow across
his sternum and it would've gotten me out.
And as we,
as we looked at it, you
know, because once I was out,
then we went over it for a few minutes
just to just try and analyze what
happened. And I realized that, you know,
that I had held on to this rule of mine,
even though part of me was like, you
know, what should I try it? And I didn't,
I didn't try it.
And so then I got a worse position
or worse position or worse position.
So the lesson learned is that sometimes
you've got to break your rules.
Now the thing is,
it's not just Jujitsu,
right? It's not just
Jujitsu, it's about business,
it's about life,
it's about relationships.
It's about not getting stuck in a Rut.
And it's being
able, because it's another thing
is I, I was in my own head,
I didn't detach from the situation.
I didn't look at it from another
position and say, okay, you know,
this is getting worse right now.
I just was stuck there mentally.
So you gotta think you gotta you gotta
think about your rules objectively.
And I didn't do that. And it's a rule
that has, has, has saved me many times,
but this time it,
it cost me nearly dearly.
So don't let your rules rule you.
You gotta keep ruling your rules, don't
let you rules rule you. Yeah. You, um,
another way to kind of look at that as
like a black and white mind, you know,
like don't stick it in your mind is
more or less black and white for sure.
Well, as far as how you
think, generally speaking,
but don't neglect the gray is so much
gray in there. And of course, you know,
if you ever rules in their solid
rules, man, yes, stick to those rules.
But like I said,
don't neglect the gray.
You know how you say you got to break
rule every once in a while. Don't be just,
hey, ruler meant to be broken. Let's
just break it. Not, don't do that.
People can use that as a, uh,
some people use that as a, uh,
excuse just to do whatever they
yeah, exactly. They're wrong too.
They lack the discipline.
Next question. Let's do it. I'm glad
you used that amount of skip by the way,
check.
Do you have any advice on consoling a
member of your team that you're leading?
Who knows they're to
blame for the project?
Failing or falling through the
person in question is a great worker,
but just made an honest mistake that cost
that caused the failure of the project.
They feel extremely guilty for putting
my job at risk and I can't convey to them
enough that I understand it was an honest
mistake and then I personally failed
to communicate enough with them.
I think it's a great thing this
person is so passionate at their job,
but is there any way I can get them to
distance themselves and show them that
this one failure is
not that big of a deal?
So,
um, yeah, like, like the,
the question says it's cool that you
got somebody that's passionate. Right.
That's great.
And it sounds like they want to
take ownership and that's great too.
It sounds like they are having
trouble moving on. So in this case,
no, no major complications.
Is it not that big of a deal?
You just got to talk them through it.
And for me,
I would use probably some kind of sub,
you know,
some stories are real simple.
One is like about parachuting
and if you're parachuting,
one of the main training
points when you're parachuting
and something goes wrong
is you don't get focused on just trying
to fix the bad shoot because that's what
gets people killed. They're
looking up, they maybe they can
save the shoot,
they think they can make an open somehow.
And the next thing you know,
they hit the ground right and they die.
So what they do is they,
they teach you that, hey,
you got a bad shoot.
You know,
you pull your main parachute
and it doesn't open correctly.
You take a look at it, you go, okay,
is this thing gonna open or not?
You make a decision and then you cut it
away and it's gone and you focus on the
next thing, which is getting your reserve
fair. She'd come out to save your life.
The one that didn't open, it
doesn't matter anymore. So move on.
You can think about it like a, uh,
like a shooting competition too.
Cause it's the same thing.
You, when you're shooting,
you don't want to shoot.
You didn't want to think about the last
shot that you just missed and you don't
want to think about the next shot that's
a hard shot or a far shot or you don't
want to think about those other shots.
You want to think about the
shot that you're taking.
That's the one that you
want to think about.
And if you're getting caught in the past,
it's going to ruin what you're trying
to do in the present. So you, you know,
you have to move on. This is
something that this, you know,
you got to explain to your employee
that's good. You'd look, listen,
I understand that you, that you had a
rough time. If you can't let that go,
it's going to screw up the project we're
working on now. So let's let that go.
Let's move on. So that's what I'd
say to them. Say, listen, look buddy,
I know this one went bad. I get it.
You feel bad. Appreciate it. It's over.
It's in the past. Let's take the
lessons learned and we got to move on.
Let's not dwell on yesterday.
If we dwell on yesterday,
it takes our focus off
of today and tomorrow,
which are the things we
can actually control.
We can actually control
what we're doing today.
We can actually control what
we're going to do tomorrow.
We don't have any control over what
happened yesterday that's gone.
So what I need you to do is focus on
this mission now and making sure we
executed 100%
that that sense of or that access
to control over over a situation.
That's so critical to to know when you're
in that position because to know what
to know that that you,
you drove it to have it on the phone.
You can and cannot do what you
can control yet. Like I said,
have access to that cause it feels,
it's horse feelings though.
It feels like use the parachute analogy,
it feels like Dang,
there's the problem. The
parachute, that's the problem.
So of all my attention and all
my emotional energy is, is,
is on that, that's the
problem. But like you said,
if you just honored to focus on the fact
that hey, I can't control that bad shoe,
that pet food is gone and cutting
away and yeah, focusing on the thing.
But like I said, man, that's the,
that's the key right there to
understand that men, you don't,
you don't have control over that anymore.
We're done with that.
We're not doing that anymore.
Yeah.
And you know,
I should have said that on the last
one about talking about breaking rules.
I said business, I said life, I forgot
to say combat, but combat's the same way.
If you get stuck in a standard operating
procedure and you won't see your way
out of it, you're gonna, you're gonna
pay and to, same thing in combat.
If you make one bad decision on the
battlefield and now you start dwelling on
that bad decision, you've got to
forget about that. You got to move on,
you got to move forward. So, you
know, the only reason you look back,
it's just assessed the lessons learned.
You're going to take away from it and
then turn back around and look forward.
Don't get sucked into the past and get
drowned and pulled back there cause you
can't control it. You can't change
what happened. Yeah. Move on buddy.
That other question,
the black and white mine one or
are you breaking your own rules?
You're one rule kind of like,
um, on, on Ghostbusters one.
Don't cross the streams you ever
watch goes with, yeah. Same thing man.
But then they had to eventually write,
they had to cross the streams streams
to kill that. The daemon. Yeah.
You're leading shit man. I think you
actually intentionally tried to do this.
That was a little reach outs. A little
regional. Those are understandable terms.
Okay.
Juggle.
What's the best advice heading into the
military? Straight from high school.
And this, this question is actually from,
uh, my brothers from down under Cain,
Dover and Nicholas Bennet.
And they've been, uh,
they've been down there in Australia,
getting there,
getting there 4:00 AM wake up
challenge on for about, I don't know,
35 or 40 days there at this point.
And what's cool,
what's been cool is hearing their feedback
as they've kind of turned their lives
around and they're getting all this
stuff done. And actually, you know,
it was hilarious. He sent, uh,
one of them said a tweet with a picture
of a text conversation with some company
that they were trying to work
with and he said something like,
the time on the tweet was f,
you know,
five oh one in the morning or something
like that. And you know, he said, hey,
are you still offering blank
or some program or whatever.
And then the response was,
yes, we are still offering
that. And then, and then the,
you know, the reply was, okay,
I'm really interested in accessing
that program or whatever.
And the response was, okay, but
don't text people at 5:00 AM.
And then the response to that
was, okay, wake up earlier. Yeah.
Which I thought that was classic.
So those guys are rocking.
It's very cool to see. Uh, so,
and it's actually one of the,
and I forget which one of them, one of
those brothers is going in the military,
which is awesome.
Very cool.
To See Australian military
work with them a little bit,
actually work with them
on a small level a lot.
Meaning that I work with a couple of
their soldiers a lot over the years,
but I never worked with them in a big
unit, but they were great guys. Uh,
here's a couple real simple things and
I'm assuming that he's going into some
kind of army or some kind of ground force.
He's going to be a trooper on the ground,
obviously be in shape,
do runs, do pushups, do
sit ups, do pull ups.
I would say be ready to march in boots.
That's one of the things that you do in
any infantry unit that is shocking to
civilians,
is putting on boots and putting on
rucksacks and walking long distances.
Why did, do your feet get like
you're faking trashed? It's,
it's just a different kind of exercise.
You know,
we talked about before humper rock man,
you gotta just put on a rock and hump a
rock and you got to wear whatever foot
where they're going to supply you.
Try and get the closest thing to that
and get your feet ready for it so that
you, so that you don't get your feet
destroyed. Be comfortable in the water.
So most military has some kind
of water testing, you know,
where they're going to throw you in
the pool, whatever. Uh, you know,
going with a normal haircut,
it's not going to make that big of a
deal because you know they're going to
shave your head within moments of showing
up. So that's not that big of a deal,
but a detached, okay, you're going to
get these crappy situations. Worse.
People knew yelling at you, they're
making you much stuff. Just detach. Just,
just detach and watch it.
Cause the drill instructors are hilarious.
And if you're, if you're
getting, if they're in your
face, you can be like, damn,
this is harsh.
But if they're in your face,
but you're watching it
from a free place of mind,
it's so awesome to watch and it's so fun.
It's so easy to understand
what they're doing. You know,
you got to remember they're not going
to kill you in training, uh, and,
and enjoy it.
I had fun,
I had fun in all my indoctrination
courses, which is, you know,
you're all your courses where you're
getting treated like a recruit.
So for me it was bootcamp, it was
bud's, it was airborne school and,
and really an ocs to officer
candidate school. All those things.
I had a great time.
I had had a blast at those schools.
I had fun getting indoctrinated,
I embraced the little rules that
they throw on outside of on,
and I take them to the extreme and I,
that's, that's how I ended up having fun,
fun with it. And then the
last thing I would say, and,
and I actually, I almost
missed this, but this is,
this might be the most important
thing. Okay. So you're 18 years old,
you just got done with high school. You
show up in the military and guess what?
You start getting a paycheck.
All of a sudden you're the richest guy
in the world because it Mickey D's,
you were making seven 50 an hour and
all of a sudden now you're getting a fat
paycheck. Have, you know, $2,200 a month.
But you don't have any expenses cause
you're in the barracks or whatever.
You've got all your food coming to you.
So what are you going to
do with that money? Well, a
lot of guys in the military,
what they do with that
money is they blow it,
they blow it on women and whiskey
and they get the big toys, right?
They get the massive toys,
they get the massive trucks and
motorcycles and Harley's and,
and everything like got, I'm not,
I got nothing against those things.
But what you need to do is
save your money and you know,
they throw figures around 15% of
your paycheck, 20% of your paycheck,
10% of your paycheck,
but put that money somewhere longterm
where you're going to grow it.
And then I would tell you,
you know, just buy a house,
buy a house and then rent out the rooms
to three guys and you sleep on the couch
and have them be paying your mortgage.
And when you get them all stabilized
in that mortgage is kind of covered.
Go buy another house and
do that every few years.
And there's no reason
to retire from the military and
not be completely set. Well,
you'd ever have to work again if you
just don't blow all your money on stuff
that you don't need. And I'm not saying
you got to live like a monk, right?
But just don't blow all of it.
Blow some of it.
Don't blow all of it. And that's a,
that's a real important to all the,
all the folks joined the military or
nude in the military. You, you can, uh,
you can make that happen.
Financial discipline equals financial
freedom. There you go. That's good.
Next question. I'm a
firefighter. Slash. Paramedic.
Historically, my profession has
always been composed of Alpha men
and all he had to worry about with
teaching the skill and not the aggressive
side of a person that
is key within this job.
We now face the new generation
where they're hiring,
thought they're hiring softer men,
quote unquote softer men due to upper
management and human resources criteria.
So when you, when you get these guys
that drive that is needed to do the job,
it's not there.
I truly,
I truly believe that our
profession is a calling. Uh,
that goes for all public servants in
military alike. So my question to you is,
how do you instill aggression or passion?
How do you instill it?
How do you turn a soft man into
an Alpha male skill can be taught,
but aggression and passion
is where I come up short,
intend to get frustrated because some
people don't love this job the way I do.
Those soft men will potentially be put
in a position where they may have to pull
me out of a fire or even save someone's
life. And aggression will be key.
Call me crazy.
But I'd rather have the Alpha male they
gets after it on a daily basis to pull
me out. Yeah, no doubt about that.
You want to have the guy that's going to
be aggressive and make things happen at
the moment of truth. So how do you do
that? How do you instill that? Well,
number one, hard training. You know, you
got to set up training for your people.
That is tough, that challenges them.
And at first there'll be some, you know,
complaining about it and whatever else.
But eventually people start to embrace
that heart draining and it starts to make
them feel proud.
And that's what you want them to do.
You want to push them mentally and
physically and you want to have them
understand a very important
premise because if you take
the fact that these guys
are, let's call them softer,
well that means they,
they want to have like, you know,
they want to be safe, right? Well,
you need to teach these guys that the
best way to mitigate risk is to be
aggressive, right? If you
want to mitigate risk,
the best way to mitigate
risk is to be aggressive.
So example, if you think of fights
going to happen, what's the best way to,
you know, control that
situation is to be aggressive,
if to aggressively attack the enemy.
If you're in a gun fighting situation
and someone's attacking you,
what's the best thing to do?
It's flank them and attack them.
You want to be aggressive in a firefight.
If you're fighting a fire,
you want to fight the fire,
right?
You don't want to let the fire
burn and get out of control.
You want to aggressively
get the fire under control.
So aggression is the best
way to mitigate risks.
So get these guys in that mentality of
where they recognize that the aggression
is an important facet
of what they're doing.
And you want to put them in training
scenarios where the aggression wins and
passivity loses. You know, you want to put
them in situation where, Oh, guess what?
You sat back and waited and now
we've got the whole building on fire.
Or you sat back and waited and now the
people that we could rescue three minutes
ago are going to die because you
hesitated at the moment of truth.
So you gotta teach them
that aggressiveness over
and over and over again.
And I think that's, that's,
that's what you gotta do. Um,
I know that
I want one at once.
You'll officer that I was working with,
we are going through land warfare training
and land warfare training is you got
machine guns firing, you got rockets
going off, you've got smoke grenades,
it's mayhem.
And if you're gonna,
you have to grab control of the situation.
So you're doing what we call immediate
action drills and everyone's shooting
live fire and they're maneuvering
and you've got to grab control of the
situation and you've got to make things
happen aggressively through force of
will. And so this once you officer
who I thought was great guy, he, he,
he like wasn't making it happen.
He wasn't being aggressive enough.
And I said to him, I said, hey
man, you got to be more aggressive.
You've got to get you going to get
fired up with your guys. And he said,
I literally said to me, I remember
it like it was yesterday. He goes,
I don't know if I can get any
more fired up. And I said,
okay, hang with me. And I just,
just,
just follow me.
And I took command of his
squad of eight guys and I said,
just follow me.
So we went,
we got into contact drill and
the shooting started and boom,
I showed him what aggression look like.
Hey [inaudible] jokes that
upon us corner right there,
you get up there and started laying down,
fire you over here start getting head
count that you yelling, placing guys,
making it happen through force of will.
It's being aggressive.
And it was,
that was all it took was like he just
didn't understand the difference.
He didn't understand what aggression
look like and he didn't understand how it
impacted the situation. When you're not
being aggressive out on the battlefield,
the you have no control,
things will, things will just,
things will just happen and you
will have no control over them. So,
and guess what?
It's the same thing in life.
If you're not aggressively
pursuing your goals again,
that doesn't mean you're aggressively
confronting people at every turn.
No,
it means you're aggressively pursuing
your goals through any means necessary.
It does. Again, people get confused and
think that I'm in someone's place. Hey,
we're doing this my way. No, no, no.
You're aggressively pursuing your goals.
You're not aggressively pursuing people.
You're not aggressively
pursuing personalities.
You're not aggressively confronting
people. You're confronting the challenge,
not the people. Do you have to confront
people? Sometimes? Yes, of course you do,
but you're aggressively confronting
and attacking the challenge,
the mission, not the
people, but he, but anyways,
this guy didn't quite understand,
so I had to show him.
I had to let him see what
that looked like, what it
looked like to say, you know,
hey, take it out right here. Grab a
guy and say stat a corner right here.
Start moving guys. And, and have
them see that. And guess what?
Then you get at the other people in the,
in the squad start seeing
it and they start acting,
acting aggressively to make things happen.
And that's,
that's when you do it. That's,
that's, that's what you do. And,
and obviously what that
means is you as a leader,
you have to lead.
You have to show these guys the way w
how important aggression is and how to do
it.
Yeah. In kind of in life, I
think you can, because again,
it's one of those things that,
that sounds pretty simple.
It's either be aggressive or you're
not being aggressive kind of thing.
But it's so hard because like for example,
if you're in life,
a lot of people they sit back and
wait for things to kind of happen.
Like while I'm waiting,
you know,
you hear people say and he just hasn't
happened for me yet and I'm waiting for
my big break kind of thing. No
wrong attitude. Yeah, exactly.
But when you're in that situation it
kind of seems like that's how the world
works.
So it doesn't and a lot of it maybe how
people are raised, I don't know. Um,
where if,
if you don't know what that is,
that if you don't have access to that
feeling of being an aggressive person,
it's hard to get there until like how
you said if someone shows you like in the
exact situation that you're in and in
your case it was that one specific Gulf
training situation you showed them
how so it probably clicked right away.
But in life there's all these situations.
So just to be an aggressive person might
be kind of hard for someone to access
unless they had like a mentor or
something or someone who demonstrated it.
Definitely is.
It definitely is hard in life.
It's hard to show people all the different
situations and because then you also
can end up with people that
are overly aggressive, right?
Or aggressive on the wrong
thing, aggressive in the
wrong direction. You know?
I said,
this is something that someone,
the other day they were talking about
being there, talking about like,
I'm super passionate about
this, and I said, don't aim.
You're passionate the people. Yeah,
because people find that offensive. Yeah.
You got to aim your passion at
the mission and let live. I mean,
there'll be some collateral encouragement
when people see someone that's fired
up.
When people see someone that's passionate,
it makes people excited
about the mission as well.
But if I hit you with my passion,
if I aim my passion at you,
all of a sudden you're intimidated by
it. You're turned off by it, you're deaf,
made defensive by it.
And so that's what you have to be careful.
If you want to aim your passion,
aim your aggression at the mission,
not at the people.
What you want to do with people
that you want to influence them.
You want to steer them,
you want to pull them along,
you want to make them give them the idea.
So they think that they're moving
in that direction on their own.
You actually want them to
be, nevermind. Thank you.
Want them to move in that direction
on their own. That's leadership.
And so that's what you got to do
with this aggressive thing. It's uh,
it's definitely a really good question.
I would also say, you know what,
what music are they listening to? What,
what, what TV shows are they watching?
What movies are they watching?
Are they watching UFC straight up?
Are they watching people fight?
Are you doing any training?
Are you hitting bags?
Are you throwing some Moy Thai kicks?
Are you grappling, you know, do
those things raise aggression levels?
Are they working out hard?
You know, like no kidding.
Squatting heavy weights increases
your testosterone period.
It really does.
So get on the squat rack and start
getting that testosterone flowing through
your system.
Let's go to the next question.
Okay. Be Aggressive on that one.
Just be aggressive and lead aggressively.
Yeah. Funny how you mentioned UFC,
cause you can kind of in that regard
you can learn a little bit cause you can
hear like you always hear the coach
or whatever yelling thing be first,
be first, be first, I'll count
and stuff like that. Yeah.
You definitely don't hear him say hey
sit back and wait to get attached. Yeah,
exactly. Then you don't really ever say,
okay, be defensive. Yeah. Or be passing.
Yeah, exactly. It doesn't happen.
Next question. Um, some Jujitsu talk.
What type of style do you
play? Aggressive, passive,
reactive or smashing paths,
et Cetera,
et cetera. Well, I mean I've
trained with you. You probably,
you know, have an assessment,
your assessment of my game,
which will be a limited
assessment by the way,
because the game that I show you is the,
is the,
is built to contend with
what you bring to the table.
If you brought something else,
you'd see something else. Yeah.
And I have a little bit
beyond that because I witness
you and dean all the time.
More so before that nowadays. But yeah, I
would say my assessment. Yeah. Okay. Yeah.
So you watch me other
people and you can see.
So you do see that I trained different
ways with other people. Yeah.
And really that's really the core
of the evaluation is that you, you,
when you roll with people,
you, it's like you're real. Um,
it's like variable style,
you know, it changes. So,
and it depends on your mood too.
Like if you're just messing around with
me or whatever, you're like, you know,
this is kind of weird, but you do
this thing that no one really does.
And you look like you look me in the eye,
like while you're rolling,
it's weird because I know you're
just messing with me. Like, oh,
like everything I do, you're like,
oh, that was cute. Kind of private,
kind of an attitude. And then,
you know, if I talked too
much, um, you know, whatever,
then you'll, you'll smash and
pass. So in regards to these,
these choices, um, all, all,
all of the above, right? So,
so passive when you're kind of taunting
and maybe even learning or not learning
style of Jujitsu. Yes. Yes
it is. It's your style.
And so you'll be passive kind of
waiting for me to do something.
And then if it doesn't work,
then you taught some more.
And then so that's passive and
reactive is obviously, you know,
reacting to anything that I try to do
aggressive is when either time runs is
running short or I talk too much and
smash and pass is the result of that
aggressive stuff in really in replace
of smash and pass. Oh, I mean,
I think the alternative for me is,
is a little something that we like
to call the disrespect, disrespect.
We just wouldn't,
it just completely disrespect the person's
guard and just pass and smash them.
Yeah, yeah. The disrespect for sure.
Yeah. And I think, I think, I think the
key point for this for me is that
I,
I know like I, I agree with you.
Like I have a decent guard. Um,
I have a good top position, pretty good
at card passing, whatever. I'm not,
I'm not great at Jujitsu,
but I'm decent at some areas and I'm pre,
one thing I am is, I'm pretty comfortable,
like in just about any situation,
there's no situation where I'm, there's
no situation where I'm freaked out.
Like I don't mind being in half guard.
I don't mind being on a half guard,
top bottom. I don't mind being
guard, closed, open, whatever.
I don't mind being mounted. I can pretty
much handle any situation, you know?
And again, when you're training with
dean, it's did, you know, you get,
you get very comfortable
with people because you have
a guy that's just a savage.
And um, but, but what's,
what's interesting about this is for
me, and I, and I talked about this,
I mean I talk about this,
there's a dichotomy here, right?
Like if being aggressive is not working,
then you have to try that other game.
You know, I always say if you're,
if you're trying to pass someone's guard
really close and you can't do it back
away because there's an opening
there and it's the same again,
it's the same thing with life,
right?
If you're beating your head against the
wall, try different route. When there's
one door that's closed or
heavily defended in combat,
go find another door, go breach
a window, go find another way.
There is an opening somewhere else.
And I think that's what my game is.
I think that's what my game is, is
it's like you said variable. Yeah.
Based on a variety of
influences both in my world
and in my opponent's world.
Yeah.
And surprisingly,
and I think that people,
a lot of people wouldn't really assume
this right away. Is that your um,
yeah, sure. You're going to smash and
you're aggressive and kind of rough.
I'll let you know a lot of
times, but you're like, um,
like a playful Jujitsu guy.
You know,
I was going to say this and this is,
I think this is important.
I had a guy ask me, how
hard do you go? Right?
And the answer's very easy.
I go just hard enough that I'm
staying ahead of the other person
now with you.
So those of you that are listening on
audio echoes making a face because there
are times when I have to step
up my game a little bit and,
and put the wood on times where
it's straight up. That's not true.
Okay. Okay. Yeah. But
there might be some, oh,
you know why that's because
you come in with you.
We sometimes you come in with a,
you know, with an attitude of, yeah,
I can see it in your eyes.
You're like,
today's the day you come in there and
you got the series look on your face now.
Okay, cool. It's going to be like
that right on and see that. Yeah.
I have to bring in the eat a little bit.
Yeah, yeah. Fully. Yeah. But that same,
and this is the part where I think is
kind of kind of interesting is that you
do, it doesn't seem like a
war. Like it seems like a war,
but all within the confines of some silly,
not silly, but some game. Well game.
Yeah. But, but it's, it's
obvious though, you know, like I,
I think that someone who may be maybe
never seen your role or never had
that experience with you specifically,
they would assume that you're this like,
hey [inaudible] I'm going to smash it.
And that meant in that I am taking
this really seriously. You know,
some guys are like
that. Yeah, that's true.
It's not that I don't take
Jujitsu seriously, but did
you too? It's fun to me.
So fun to me. Yeah. And I
think that the better you get,
the more fun it gets and the less you
have to be like that, you know, in,
I don't mind when people come at me like
that cause I still get to do the same
thing. You know? I still get to have
fun and yeah know Jujitsu should be fun.
You really should be fun,
have fun or it is for you.
The longer you're going to do it for now.
Part of the fun can be submitting people
and you get people that that's the only
fund that they have in Jujitsu
is when they submit people.
And that's not what I'm talking about.
Yeah.
I think that's kind of the
transitions and the, the,
the flowing and the utilizations
of moves and the cool things that,
and you don't, sometimes I'll be rolling
with whoever and it's like something,
just something like someone
will do something really
cool and you start laughing
like the hand, that was awesome.
That's Jujitsu. That's right.
You did two should be fun. It
shouldn't be this. Uh, it shouldn't be,
it shouldn't be. The Fun shouldn't come
from just submitting people. Right.
That's just bullying, right? Yeah.
In a way. Yeah. And you know,
you shouldn't get, you should a certain
point, you go, you know what? Okay, cool.
I can tap people out, but let's, let's,
let's do this for the reason of the
Dysport itself, the, the game itself,
which is a fun game.
Yeah.
I know guys who told me straight up
that when they're driving up to the gym,
they have anxiety. Yeah. Anxiety.
Like, Oh God, am I going to do,
or if they get tapped out, it ruins their
day or their week or whatever. But no,
I have none of that heads.
Yeah,
I'm rolling at the John
Jim just in totally,
totally happy to be,
to be getting there and get and get to
do something that's so fun. Yeah. Yeah.
I rolled with the Chris Martin today for,
and it was all like,
you can make jokes,
you can talk trash and you can do all
this stuff while you're rolling and doing
that in this playful, I mean, don't be a
Dick, you know, but, but you know, yeah,
you can't, he can push being a dick
sometimes it makes it more fun for sure.
Like you can,
you know,
you can call a move and then do it on
the guy if you're better than him or
whatever. Cold blooded. But it makes it
fun though, you know? And me and Chris,
we were doing that the whole
time. I'm like, oh Ooh, how's
that feel kind of thing.
And of course that's taken to an extreme
because I know Chris for a long time,
but talk a little bit of
that makes it more fun.
Just like if you're playing a video game,
just like if you're playing
any other games, just talk
to them. Friends, you know,
it's, it's part of the
fun. And like I said,
my original point is I think people
wouldn't assume that about you,
given how you may come off sometimes,
but you're really like that. Hmm.
No, I do do to phone to me,
no doubt on splurge for sure.
Believe you're not Jujitsu in a way,
like when you're surfing in California,
there's, uh, there's a much
harder vibe surfing in California.
There isn't the mats for sure.
Oh yeah. You know, when, you
know, when we're surfing,
where I serve,
like it's,
it's a gang mentality type situation,
you know? And so on the mats,
it's just so fun to be in a
situation and surfing, you know,
leads to fighting often oil and so,
but in Jujitsu,
the fighting is already happening,
right? So, so it's, you know, you can,
you're kind of over it and now, now
we're just, we're already fighting,
so now we can just chill, right?
Yeah, yeah. Sorry. It's crazy.
I'll surfing's like that. Right. Seems
to be this kind of zen thing. No, no, no,
you're supposed to, but it's
not, it's an aggressive,
it's a very aggressive environment.
Like a territorial thing.
It's a very territorial thing. Yeah.
Yeah. I bet it's kind of cool. I like it.
Like that
next question.
I understand and agree with all your
thoughts and principles. However,
however I interpret your concepts for
leaders leading men were mostly driven or
other leaders who have,
um,
a desire to make themselves better
in maintaining the status. Yep.
So common misperception,
right? Is that, you know,
the military and the seals,
I see this all time.
Everyone thinks that the
military in the seals,
I think that we're leading
terminator robots, right?
And everyone is just driven and
they're going to get up and going to do
everything. And it's, I just talked
about this on the last podcast.
It is a bell curve.
It is a bell curve and there's a great
bunch of guys at the top of the bell
curve that are go getters.
There's a solid bunch of
guys in the middle and then
there's the lower guys that
are bumps.
And so this interpretation that the
concepts that I talk about are just for
leading these front,
running a personalities that
just make everything happen.
N Not correct.
You know there are seals
that don't want to work.
There are seals that
want to take shortcuts.
There are seals that want to skate by.
Then you get outside,
then you're working with Iraqi soldiers
that are unmotivated, untrained,
poorly equipped. We got to work
with these guys. We got bosses.
I mean I got bosses in the seal teams
that are either an egomaniac or that are
old term risk averse.
You could have any of this stuff going on.
You can have your guys
that are risk averse.
You can have guys that are too crazy.
You got all, you know what they are.
They're humans, they're
individuals. They're human beings.
And because they're human beings, even in
special operations and sometimes it is,
especially in in special operations cause
when you get in special operations you
get guys that have huge
egos and attitudes and so,
oh you think that they just want to
do whatever you tell them to do. No,
they got their own idea. They got to go
their own method. They got their own plan,
they got their own, what they
think they are. Tactical genius.
So you got to get around that.
So what does it mean?
It means you have to lead them and it's
the common theme that I'm talking about
all the time and it was,
I mean you got to build relationships,
you got to build the trust,
you've got to make sure they understand
why they're doing what they're doing.
You've got to make sure they
understand the strategic and back.
You got to empower them. You got to set a
good example. You got to listen to them,
you got to take input, you got
to give them responsibility. And,
and when I say responsibility,
I mean real responsibility.
You've got to build them up.
You've got to make them better.
You got to show them and let them see.
Not In a, not in a, in your face way,
but you've got to subtly let them see
what self improvement means them and how
they can better their position
and what drive we'll get them.
He got to them ownership of stuff.
And you got to let that ownership grow
into extreme ownership where they really
want to own things and you got to teach
them to lead and you got to put them in
leadership positions and you gotta show
your trust by actually following them
sometimes and again, people
ask me these questions.
You know how I'm a new leader?
How do I lead? I got a new person.
How do I lead them? It's the same answers.
It's the same answers all the time.
That principles of leadership
now the nuances are there. Yes,
the nuances are there and I,
I have to nuance for echo that I got a
nuance for this guy over here and I got a
nuance for this group over here.
The the nuances are there,
but the basic principles are the
same. Am I never, am I going to?
Who am I going to be in charge of that?
I'm not going to try and build a
relationship of trust with them.
Who's that dancers? Nobody. You know?
Who is it that I don't want to set?
A good example for the answer is nobody.
Who is it that I'm not going to listen to?
If you don't listen to people,
you alienate them and you don't want
to be part of the team. I mean it's,
it's the things are universal
and again,
there's nuances because you might have to
make adaptations. And you know, when we,
when we did battle leadership
with, uh, with, uh,
eight off von Shell and he talks about
distinctly these three different types of
commanders and how the boss gave them
each their own little adjusted order
because he was dealing with
their personalities. So yes,
you've got to deal with the personalities,
but that doesn't mean you're doing
something different from the principals.
So
when you get, sure, when you get to
the bottom of the bell curve, it,
you might see some people that
might need to be replaced,
they might need to be removed,
but I'll tell you what,
most likely they just need to be led.
Mm.
The reason that our,
I think one of the reasons why it,
the perception is that all your
guys are robots and you know,
I'm going to give you an order.
They follow it.
No questions that is is like movies,
right?
Like a few good men membered
Jack Nicholson. He's like,
people will follow orders or people
die. Yeah. That was his thing.
And they say that kind of
stuff. Yeah. And but they do,
they do capture in some Hollywood movies
where they show how mute knees take
place and how things go
wrong and how, you know, the,
the new lieutenant Vietnam is going
to get fragged by his own people.
That stuff's real. Yeah.
You know, that stuff's real.
So it's just, it, it's a
misperception. The other thing,
the other misperception is because of
bootcamp, a lot of military movies are,
they show up, they show a significant
amount of time in bootcamp,
but bootcamp is a matter of
weeks in a career. You know,
I think Marine Corps bootcamp is 13 weeks.
I think the army bootcamp is 10 weeks.
Bootcamp is a very short period of time
in your four year, six year, eight year,
10 year, 20 year career
bootcamp is, you know,
I talked about the indoctrinational
times in the military.
They are very short periods of
time compared to your whole career.
And in bootcamp when you're Joan
instructor says dropdown and do pushups,
you dropped down a few pushups in boot
bootcamp when you're Joan instructor says
pickup that, you know, make your
bed, you make your bed when these,
and if you don't,
they yell at you and they yell at
you until you do make your bed.
So people get that idea that that's
the way the military is run. Yeah. Yup.
And that is like, you know, a great
example is full metal jacket, the movie,
which is a great movie,
but the boot camp scene is half the movie.
But in reality, even if you are
a guy in, in Vietnam, you know,
boot campus 13 weeks and then you
went onto, into Vietnam for a year.
So it's a fraction of what
your real career is like.
And so people get that impression that
you're just going to be able to bark
orders and everyone's gonna listen to
you. It just doesn't work that way. Yeah.
And there's actually, there's a
great, there's a great video. Um,
it's called Charlie
Company and V, uh, anyways,
I forget the name of the video,
but it's about a company in Vietnam,
Charlie Company. And maybe if you
remind me, I'll put it on the,
on the website. Um, it shows
two company commanders.
But anyways, to make a long
story short, these guys,
they don't like their
new company commander.
And at first they're resistant to
him and you know, he says, listen,
these guys could got to learn that there's
going to have to do. And I tell him,
and then it fast forwards a couple months
and they interview him again and he
goes, hey, you know, how's
everything going? He goes, you know,
they get it now and they realize that
they just had to listen to me and do what
I told them.
And then they go out in the field with
the guys and the guys in the fueled,
they're supposed to be doing things and
they're just not doing it. They're just,
they're literally calling back like, yeah,
where did we did, yeah, we did a patrol,
you know, they didn't do it.
Yeah, we moved positions.
They didn't move positions.
Yeah, we're gonna do another, you
know, another foot patrol tonight.
They're not doing it.
So he was under the impression that
everyone had like buckled to his will.
They were just completely
snowing him and he had no idea.
So that's what happens in the military.
If you're don't lead your people and
you just order them around and you think
that everyone's just this, this, uh,
this, uh, how would they describe it here?
Men who are mostly driven or leaders who
have a desire to make themselves better.
I mean, if anybody in a
position with guys like that,
it's going to the leadership job,
it's going to be very easy.
You just tell him what to
do and they do it. I mean,
I could give you example upon example
upon example of stuff in the seal teams
were what I had to do to get people
convinced that this was the right thing to
deal. You know, I mean, it
is like, you know, a classic
example is telling guys, okay,
we're going take Iraqi soldiers
on every operation. You know.
So these guys were saying, are you kidding
me? Well, they just didn't go, hey,
cool Jocko. We'll do exactly
what you tell us. No, they look,
what are you talking about raw taking
these guys out, why would we do that?
It's going to be risky. These guys
aren't trustworthy. They don't,
they're not trained. Right. They had
a million reasons why not to do that.
But how do you get them to do it?
You explain to them why you explained
to them the strategic importance.
You have built trust with them.
You tell them that they're going
to take ownership of the Iraqis.
I mean it's everything that I just said.
That's what you do.
That's a classic example.
So yes,
once again, you have, if you're
in a leadership position,
you have to lead.
You ever seen the movie saving
Private Ryan? Yes. Yeah.
There was a part in then and
that movie that um, that they,
they weren't down for the orders.
I remember that one.
It was kind of like a little pivotal
part where they were going to go take a,
a machine gun nests and they were
like, man, we don't have to do this.
So they all kind of got together
and said, hey, you know,
seems like unnecessary risks.
And he's like,
he kind of tripped out a little bit and
kind of forced them to do it and they
were like, all right, whatever.
Kind of reluctantly then one of the
guys died and stuff. But anyway,
that's an example of where they,
yeah.
And, and especially, you know,
when you were just doing a
talking about world war one,
that one portion of the book
where he says, you know what,
we got ordered to do this thing. I didn't
feel good about it, but it was an order,
we're going to do it. So there's
examples from the past, especially where,
you know, it's definitely was more
like that in the past and more one,
obviously it was like that obviously it
was like that unfortunately it was like
that. Yeah. Because it caused
people to continue, you know,
to execute these operations that
we're just going to get people killed.
And you know, actually Lafe and I
were talking about that last week.
Pickett's charge tickets,
charge Gettysburg,
they sent the troops up and
they got slaughtered and
they know they're survivors
came back in. Uh, Lee was, you
know, basically in tears like, Hey,
I'm sorry this happened.
I, this was my fault.
He took ownership of it and I hope
I'm getting the story right. Um,
but, but that's the,
that's the general, uh,
the general gist of the story.
But then they eat, you know,
the big story was that the guys were like,
hey, we'll go again if you, you know,
cause you're such a great leader
will go again. And Life, you know,
it was kind of like, you know, that's
what world war, you know, that's what,
that's what happened, that that shows you
that guys were willing. And I said, yeah,
but the differences in world war one,
they sent them again,
they sent them over and over. You
know, Lee was regretting and I'm sorry,
and I did something that got you got,
you know, a bunch of guys killed.
It's horrible in World War One. And like,
yeah, it happened going again. Oh yeah.
And that happens again. We're doing it
again and again and again and it's just,
uh, I'll, I'll, I'll,
I'll always just be horrified
by that and hopefully, um,
man progress's beyond that.
And again,
part of that is as a person
you have to question,
you have to be a rebel.
You have to question what people are
telling you and why they're telling it to
you. If my boss doesn't tell
me why I'm doing my operation,
it's and I continue to execute it,
that's my fault.
I need to raise my hand and say, boss,
what are we doing? Why are we doing this?
I don't understand.
You got to take that initiative because
if you're just blindly following orders,
I don't want somebody that's
blindly following orders.
I never want people that blindly follow
my orders. I want people that say, oh,
get boss, wait, why are we doing this? Why
is this happening? Because I want people,
I want think, I want leaders
underneath me that know how to lead.
And you know what?
When you build the trust and
you build the relationships,
those guys will do anything for you and
my guys and my task. They do anything.
I mean,
I know it,
they did over and over again did
operations that were crazy and hard and
dangerous and risky. Never
did anyone say, oh, you know,
we're not doing this. They said, okay,
we understand what, what's the mission?
All right.
So you got to build that road.
It's against the same basic principles
of leading human beings. Yeah.
And that's what you gotta do.
But to think that you're just going to
order people to do things not happening.
Mm. Long answer to a, to a good question.
That was actually interesting perspective.
And I know it's a perspective that a
lot of people have. People always think,
well, you know, you led seals and they
really, yeah. So that was easy. Yeah.
But before you said, before you told
me, that's Kinda what I figured. Yeah.
Last question.
Jacko any tips for Breaking Habits
of Laziness and procrastination?
Maybe some good reads on the subject.
And this is a question I wish you'd
answered for me like 10 years ago. So,
yeah. Any tips? You know,
this is definitely been a pretty common
question when people want to know how to
stop the laziness and they want to know
how to stop the procrastination and
they have some idea in their
head, you know, some kind of a,
a vision for what they want to do,
but they don't know where to start. They
don't know where to start it, you know,
they don't know where to
start. And so they say, hey,
where do I start and,
and when's the best time to start?
And I have a very simple answer for that.
Okay,
here and now.
That's it. You want to improve,
you want to get better.
You want to get on a workout
program or a clean diet.
You want to start a business,
you want
to write a book or make a movie or build
a house or a computer or put together
some mobile application.
Where do you start?
You start right here and when do
you start? You start right now.
You initiate the action aggressively.
You
go
because the idea isn't going to execute
itself and the book isn't going to write
itself and the weights out in the gym,
they're not going to move themselves.
You have to do it and
you have to do it now.
And that means you got to stop thinking
about it and stopped dreaming about it
and stop researching every aspect of it
and reading all about it and debating
the pros and cons of it.
Just start doing it.
Take that first step
and make it happen.
Get after it,
get after it here and now.
And I think, uh, I think that's
all we've got for tonight.
So
thanks everybody for listening to this,
for uh,
for putting those headphones in your ears
and pressing play and settling in with
me and sending some spending a
little bit of time in my head.
I know it's a little scary in there.
Some done this.
Thanks for the feedback that you give us
an a question you ask us and thanks for
subscribing to the podcast and downloading
it and writing reviews and spreading
the word. And thanks for buying
the book and buying the Audio Book.
Thanks for supporting the
companies that support us on it.
O n n I t.com and amazon.com
you got to click through.
So if you're going to buy Henry the fifth
tonight cause you're fired up to get
your Shakespeare together,
are you going to buy any of the other
books that we've talked about here,
which are all awesome.
Just go to Amazon and click through
from Jocko podcast.com or Jocko store.
That's how you'd do it.
And lastly, and most importantly
to everybody out there,
thanks for getting up early.
Thanks for getting in the gym.
Thanks for getting on the Mat.
Thanks for getting your grind on at work.
Getting your head into a book,
getting smarter and stronger
and faster and better.
Thanks to everybody
for getting after it.
And so until next time,
this is Jocko and echo
out.